[Music]
ANNOUNCER: THIS is Capitol TV.
[Beat, music]
DEREK: Greetings citizens. Welcome to the
Coriolanus 9 solar thermal power plant in
the heart of District 5.
This facility generates over 7% of our proud
Capitol’s energy needs.
But did you know that you can generate electricity
from mere drops of water?
I’m going to show you an experiment
that does just that.
As we turn on the water, it falls
through these rings, and onto this mesh below.
But look here. After a moment...
[Electrical buzz]
...there it is.
It generates a spark of roughly 20,000 volts
of electricity. [Electrical buzz]
And there is no power source here,
no turbine as in traditional hydro generation.
In fact, there are no moving parts at all.
We are creating electricity using only the
intrinsic properties of falling water.
So how does it work? Well, water contains
charged particles called ions.
It has equal numbers of positive and negative
ions, so overall it’s neutral.
However, as the water falls, there will sometimes
be a slight charge imbalance,
with a little bit more negative charge over
here and a bit more positive charge there.
Under ordinary circumstances, these variations
would even out over time, but not in this
case.
Here is the ingenious part - the mesh on the
left is connected to the ring on the right.
So if this mesh becomes negatively charged,
then so does this ring.
And now that ring will attract the positively
charged ions in the water,
So the mesh on the right
will now be more positively charged
meaning so is this ring
So what we have is a clear separation of charge.
There’s a positively charged stream on the
right, and a negatively charged stream on
the left.
And the more the charge builds up on the meshes,
the faster that charge increases.
And finally when we have reached our designed
operating voltage of 20,000 volts,
electrons jump from the negative rings to
the positive ones through this spark gap...
[Electrical buzz]
DEREK: ...ionizing the air as they do so.
We have created an electric generator with
little more than a stream of water droplets.
No field of mirrors or enormous coal-burning
plant is required
In fact, with access to the right
materials, you could even build this apparatus
at home.
Thank you for your attention.
We citizens of District 5 expand our knowledge
to better serve our great nation.
Love your labor, take pride in your task.
Our future is in your hands.
And, don’t forget to register for updates
from Capitol TV…it’s mandatory.